สวัสดีค่ะคุณครูหญิง
สวัสดีค่ะครูเรียมสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนครูเรียมวันนี้วันอะไร
คะวันนี้วันจันทร์ค่ะ
ค่ะวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 17
เดือนอะไรคะเดือนกรกฎาคมค่ะ
ค่ะปีพ.ศอะไรคะพ.ศ 2566
ปีค.ศอะไรคะค.ศ 2023 ค่ะ
ค่ะตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะ
ตอนนี้ 9 โมง
33 นาทีค่ะ
9 โมง 33 นาทีเนาะก็เป็นตอนเช้าวัน
จันทร์นะคะถ้านักเรียนหรือว่าใครที่ต้อง
ไปทำงาน
ก็เป็นเวลาเป็นวันแรกของการทำงานใช่แล้ว
ก็เหมือนเราเนอะอย่างครูเรียมก็เป็นวัน
แรกที่ครูเรียนก็ต้องทำงานเหมือนกันแต่
ว่าถ้าเป็นวันเสาร์หรือว่าวันอาทิตย์ใช่
ไหมคะเมื่อวานนี้เนี่ยเป็นวันอาทิตย์เนอะ
วันเสาร์วันอาทิตย์มันก็เป็นวันที่เราไม่
ต้องทำงาน
บางคนก็ชอบอยู่บ้านบางคนก็ชอบออกไปข้าง
นอกไปเจอเพื่อน
โดยปกติ
ครูเรียม
วันเสาร์วันอาทิตย์
จะออกไปข้างนอกไปเจอเพื่อนไหมคะ
วันเสาร์อาทิตย์ออกไปข้างนอกค่ะ
แต่ว่าไม่ใช่ทุกๆสัปดาห์
ใช่ค่ะเพราะว่าเรียนเสาร์อาทิตย์ก็ยังทำ
งาน
ทำงานแล้วก็ออกไปข้างนอกไปเจอเพื่อนอาจจะ
แป๊บนึงหรือว่า
ถ้าแบบถ้าไปเที่ยวกับเพื่อนคิดว่าต้องใช้
เวลานานๆวันนั้นก็จะไม่ทำงาน
แล้วก็ออกไปคุยกับเพื่อนหรือว่าเวลาที่
เพื่อนโทรศัพท์มาแล้วก็
เลี่ยมออกมาเจอหน่อยแล้วก็ได้ยินเสียง
แปลกๆ
ทำไมอ่ะเสียงอะไรอ่ะคะเสียงแบบที่มีความ
รู้สึกรู้สึกไม่ดี
เพื่อนมาเพื่อนเราแบบรู้สึกไม่ดีก็จะแบบ
โอเคๆไม่ทำงานวันนี้
เดี๋ยวจะออกไปออกไปคุยด้วยนะ
เพราะว่าถ้าเพื่อนโทรมาแล้วก็คุยโทรศัพท์
อ่ะเนอะบางทีแบบเพื่อนเพื่อนโทรหาเราเรา
ก็จะฮัลโหลเพื่อนก็ถ้าฟังที่เพื่อนพูดใช่
ไหมคะฟังเสียงของเพื่อนถ้าเพื่อนบอก
ฮัลโหลเรียมออกมาเจอได้ไหมเนี่ยฟังจาก
เสียงเพื่อนก็รู้แล้วว่าเอ๊ะ
ทำไมเสียงของเพื่อนดูไม่มีความสุข
ถ้าปกติก็เรียนฮัลโหล
ฮัลโหลเรียมออกมาเจอหน่อยได้ไหมฟังจาก
เสียงแล้วเพื่อนก็อาจจะแบบเอ๊ะเพื่อน
กำลังเศร้าอยู่หรือเปล่า
ใช่คิดว่าเป็นแบบนั้นคิดว่าเพื่อนกำลัง
เศร้าแล้วก็อยากคุยอยากคุยกับเรา
ใช่ค่ะเพราะว่าก็เป็นเพื่อนกันอะเนอะถ้า
บางทีเศร้าก็ไม่คือเพื่อนเศร้าเนี่ยอาจจะ
เป็นเพราะว่าเพื่อนอกหักก็คือเลิกกับแฟน
สมัยถ้าเพื่อนมีแฟนแล้วเลิกกับแฟนเพื่อน
ก็เศร้าใช่ไหมคะหรือจริง
ก็อาจจะไม่ได้เศร้าเรื่องที่ว่าเลิกกับ
แฟนก็ได้ก็อาจจะมีคนในครอบครัวไม่สบาย
เพื่อนก็เศร้าได้ใช่ไหมหรือว่าเพื่อน
ไม่มีเงินจ่ายค่าอภัย
หรือว่าเพื่อนอาจจะไม่สบายใช่ไหมไม่สบาย
บางทีมันเศร้าได้หลายๆเรื่องไงคะใช่ค่ะ
ครูหญิงบางครั้งที่เรารู้สึกเศร้าเรารู้
สึกเศร้าเพื่อนเห็นหน้าเราก็รู้แล้วนะ
แล้วเพื่อนก็จะหาเป็นอะไรหรือว่าบางครั้ง
เรียนไปออกกำลังกายใช่ไหมกับเพื่อนที่
ฟิตเนสเพื่อนเห็นแบบตาบวมมากตาแบบหนังตา
บวมมากแดงๆร้องไห้เหมือนร้องไห้มาเยอะๆ
ใช่ไหมคะใช่เพื่อนก็จะเริ่มถามแล้วว่า
เป็นอะไร
หนิงก็บอกเป็นอะไรทำไมหรอทำไมตาแดง
เมมก็บอกจริงหรอเห็นว่าตาแดงเลยหรอ
ดูซีรีส์เกาหลี
มันก็เศร้าเหมือนกันนะ
ไม่เป็นไรนะคะ
ใช่อันนี้ปล่อยไป
ไม่ต้องสนใจ
[เพลง]
พาเพื่อนไปกินของอร่อย
รู้สึกว่าเวลาที่เรามีเรื่องอะไรที่มัน
เศร้าไม่สบายใจไม่มีความสุขการที่เราได้
กินของอร่อยหรือว่าได้กินอาหารที่เราชอบ
กินเนี่ยมันทำให้เรามีความสุขได้ง่ายๆไง
ไม่ใช่เลยค่ะครูหญิงเคยได้ยินคำว่า
ชานมไข่มุกจะเยียวยาทุกสิ่งไหม
หมูกระทะหมูกระทะหมูกระทะจะเยียวยาทุก
สิ่ง
เพราะว่า
คือถึงแม้ว่าเราจะไม่มีความสุขนะคะแต่เรา
จะมีเรื่องให้ต้องคิดมากมีเรื่องเศร้าๆ
แต่ถ้าเราได้กินอาหารที่มันแบบว่า
อร่อยๆหรือชานมไข่มุกหรือว่าหมูกระทะ
หมูกระทะจะเยียวยาทุกสิ่ง
ใช่ค่ะตอนแรกอันนี้เพื่อนเราใช่ไหมหน้า
เป็นแบบนี้เพราะเพื่อนเนี่ยได้กินหมูกะทะ
ยิ้มเลยไม่ใช่แบบกินไปร้องไห้ไป
กินไปตอนแรก
อกหักใช่ไหมเลิกกับแฟนอันนี้เพื่อนเรานะ
คะเพื่อนเราเป็นผู้ชายเพื่อนอกหักใช่ไหม
เราบอกโอเคไม่เป็นไรเดี๋ยวเราไปกินหมู
กระทะเพื่อนก็จะ
แต่พอกินกินไปได้สักพักนึงคิดว่าเดี๋ยวก็
เลิกร้องไห้
เพราะว่ากินก่อน
มีความสุขไงหรือว่าชานมไข่มุกอย่างที่ครู
เรียมบอกใช่ไหมคะบางทีเรามีเรื่องไม่สบาย
ใจอ่ะการได้กินชานมไข่มุก 1 แก้วแล้วก็
วันนี้รู้สึกมีความสุขแล้วได้กินของที่
อร่อยๆ
ใช่อ๋ออันนี้ก็คือวิธีที่ครูหญิงทำให้
เพื่อนหายเศร้า
คุยอีกว่ายิ่งเราเป็นเพื่อนกันเนาะเราก็
จะรู้ว่าเพื่อนของเราเนี่ยเขาชอบกินอะไร
คือคนเป็นเพื่อนกันมานานๆรู้จักกันนาน
แล้วอ่ะก็จะรู้แหละว่าเพื่อนเราอ่ะชอบกิน
อะไรถ้าเพื่อนชอบกินชานมไข่มุกคือจริงๆชา
นมไข่มุกมันมีหลายๆแบรนด์แต่ถ้าเรารู้ว่า
เพื่อนชอบกินแบรนด์ไหนยี่ห้อไหนเราอาจจะ
ซื้อแล้วก็เอาไปให้เพื่อนอย่างเงี้ยมันก็
จะทำให้เพื่อนรู้สึกดีขึ้นไงหรือว่า
เพื่อนชอบกินหมูกระทะชอบกินบุฟเฟ่ต์ชอบ
กินอะไรก็ได้ค่ะเราก็พาเพื่อนไปกินของ
อร่อยๆ
ผู้หญิงว่าถ้าเป็นผู้หญิงผู้หญิงก็อาจจะ
มีความสุขขึ้นนิดนึงนะแต่ถ้าเพื่อนบางคน
เนี่ยเขาอาจจะเศร้ามากๆไงคะครูเรียมพาไป
กินของชอบของที่อร่อยถ้ายิ่งแบบ
เพิ่งเลิกกับแฟนมาได้ 1 วันอย่างนี้บางที
ชอบชานมไข่มุกมากๆชอบหมูกะทะมากๆแต่มัน
กำลังเศร้าอ่ะกำลังเสียใจอ่ะกินไม่ลงปกติ
เนี่ยเพื่อนแบบ
อร่อยมากแต่นี้มันเศร้ามากไงเพื่อนก็แบบ
กินไม่ลงอ่ะเออ
ถ้า
ใช่ค่ะแต่หน้าคุณเหลี่ยมไม่เศร้านะ
เป็นอะไร
ถ้าอาหารช่วยเพื่อนไม่ได้ก็คิดว่า
จะพาเพื่อนไปดูหนังหรอ
ไปโรงหนัง
หรออกหักมาเนี่ย
ไปดูคนเขารักกันในโรงหนังให้ร้องไห้มาก
กว่าเดิมอีกนะ
สมมุติว่าเพื่อนคนไหนเศร้าดีล่ะคนนี้แล้ว
กันไม่มี
ใครเศร้าเลย
[เพลง]
ก็พาเพื่อนไปดูหนังอย่างนี้
อาจจะต้องพาเพื่อนไปร้องคาราโอเกะ
[เพลง]
เราได้นะถ้าเพื่อนเพื่อนอยากลืมนะ
ถ้าเพื่อนอยากลืมไม่อยากคิดอย่างอื่นร้อง
คาราโอเกะก็โอเคนะถ้าเพื่อนชอบลอง
แต่ว่าบางครั้งคือหญิงเนมก็คิดว่าเดมก็
แค่นั่งแล้วก็ฟังหวังเพื่อนครูให้เพื่อน
ให้เพื่อนพูดใช่ไหมคะ
ใช่เพราะเขาไม่รู้ว่าจะพูดกับใคร
ใช่เขาก็จะพูด
พูดสิ่งที่เขาคิดออกมาออกมาเรื่อยๆ
คนเดียวก็คิดว่าเออถ้าเพื่อนได้พูดสิ่ง
ที่แบบเขาไม่สบายใจหรือว่ากาแฟอย่างนี้พอ
เขาพูดๆเล่าให้เราฟังมันก็เหมือนเอาอะไร
ที่ไม่สบายใจเนี่ยออกมา
ใช่ๆ
เสร็จแล้วก็ไปร้องคาราโอเกะต่อก็ให้
เพื่อนร้องเพลงเศร้าแล้วก็ร้องไห้ไปด้วย
ร้องเพลงไปด้วยจะหายนะเพื่อนน่าจะมีความ
สุขขึ้นใช่ค่ะคือหญิงสำหรับเรียงนะเจนคิด
ว่าเวลาที่มีคนเศร้าเสียใจ
เอมจะใช้วิธีการฟัง
ฟังเขาแล้วก็ถามถามว่าเวลาที่เขาบอกว่า
เลิกกับแฟนคนนี้แล้วเสียใจมากเลยริมก็จะ
พูดในสิ่งที่เขาพูดอีกครั้งหนึ่งว่าอ๋อ
เธอเสียใจใช่ไหมกับแฟนคนนี้แล้วทำไมล่ะ
ทำไมถึงเข้าใจจะถามแบบนี้ทำไมถึงเสียใจ
เพราะว่ามันไม่มีใครเพื่อนก็จะพูดออกมา
แล้วเรียมก็จะเหมือนแบบถามเขาว่าสิ่งที่
เขาพูดคือแบบนี้ใช่ไหมก็คือพูดซ้ำกับที่
เขาพูดออกมา
ใช่เขาก็จะได้ยินว่าตัวเองคิดอะไร
แล้วก็พูดอะไรออกมาใช่จะแบบได้รวมความคิด
ว่าสรุปแล้วเนี่ย
เรากำลังทำอะไรอยู่
แล้วมันควรร้องไห้จริงๆไหมเพราะบางครั้ง
สิ่งที่เขาพูดออกมาก็คือแฟนไม่ดีแฟนไม่ดี
แล้วเรียนก็จะพูดอ๋อแฟนไม่ดีใช่ไหมไม่ดี
อ่ะข้อ 1 ไม่ดีข้อ 2 ไม่ดีข้อ 3 แล้วสุด
ท้ายเขาได้ฟังสิ่งที่เราพูดเขาก็จะคิดได้
ว่าเออแล้วร้องไห้ทำไมวะก็ดีแล้วไม่เจอ
เขาไม่ดีก็ปล่อยเขาไปสิ
เลิกกับคนไม่ดีต้องดีใจไหม
ร้องคาราโอเกะ
เพราะว่าร้องคาราโอเกะมันก็เหมือนเล่าให้
เพื่อนฟังเวลาที่เราไปร้องเพลงใช่ไหมเรา
อาจจะไม่ต้องไปร้านคาราโอเกะก็ได้อยู่ที่
บ้านอย่างนี้เปิดคอมหรือว่าไปตู้
คาราโอเกะแล้วเพื่อนก็จะเลือกใช่ไหมคะ
เลือกเพลงถ้าเพื่อนเนี่ยอกหักเลิกกับแฟน
ก็เลือกเพลงเศร้าๆก็ร้องเพลงไปร้องไห้ไป
มันก็เหมือนได้ออกความเศร้าความเสียใจ
มันก็อาจจะทำให้รู้สึกเออดีขึ้นเพื่อนอาจ
จะมีความสุข
ก็แบบมีอยู่หลายวิธีเหมือนกันนะบางครั้ง
ก็พาไปเที่ยวเลยไปเที่ยวแบบทะเล
ใช่หรือว่าบางครั้งก็ถ้าไม่ได้อยากไป
เที่ยวจริงๆถ้าเรามีรถน่ะเนาะมีรถก็ขับรถ
เล่นก็ได้นะ
สมมุติว่าจากอาจจะจากบ้านอย่างนี้ค่ะอยู่
สูงถ้าอยู่กรุงเทพฯแล้วกันเนาะแล้วก็ขับ
รถลงไปหัวหินตรงทางอ่ะเวลาขับรถก็คือ
รถใช่ไหมคะมันจะมีหน้าต่างเขาเรียก
หน้าต่างไม่ค่อยกระจกกระจกรถส่วนใหญ่ที่
ไทยเนี่ยเราจะปิดกระจกเพราะว่ามันร้อนเรา
ก็เปิดแอร์ทีนี้เนี่ยถ้าเพื่อนกำลังเศร้า
เราก็อาจจะลดกระจกลงให้ลมลมจะทะเลไม่ใช่
กรุงเทพฯนะคือกรุงเทพฯเนี่ยไม่ได้นะคะ
เพราะว่ารถมันจะติดรถเยอะถ้าเราปรับกระจก
หรือเล่นอะไรนะรถกระจกรถลง
เพื่อนก็จะได้แบบ
คาร์บอนมอนอกไซด์คาร์บอนมอนอันนี้ต้องแบบ
ขับออกไปไกลๆที่แบบเป็นถนนที่ติดกับทะเล
อาจจะเป็นหัวหินก็ได้หรือว่าขับไปทาง
ชลบุรีระยองอย่างนี้ค่ะแล้วก็แบบมีลมเรา
ก็ไม่ต้องพูดอะไรก็ได้เนาะก็ขับรถแล้วก็
ให้เพื่อนเนี่ยดูวิวไปมันก็เห็นอะไรที่
มันดูเป็นธรรมชาติ
เป็นทะเลอากาศดีๆก็อาจจะทำให้เพื่อนเสร็จ
แล้วครูเรียนก็ถามแล้วเดี๋ยวเพื่อนก็เล่า
ก็อาจจะทำให้แบบเพื่อนรู้สึกดีขึ้นก็ได้
นะคะจากความเศร้าต่างๆ
ใช่ๆค่ะผู้หญิงเป็นแบบนั้นก็จะทำให้เขา
รู้สึกแบบสบายใจได้ดูวิวสวยๆนะ
แบบนั้นก็ช่วยได้แต่ว่าก็ต้องมีเงินด้วย
นะเวลาที่แบบเวลาที่เศร้าอ่ะไม่รู้นะ
เรียมเคยคุยกับเพื่อน
ไม่ว่าจะเศร้าเสียใจหรือว่ามีความสุขถ้า
เกิดเราทำงานแล้วก็เก็บเงินไว้อ่ะดีแล้ว
เวลาที่เราเวลาที่เราเศร้าแล้วแบบไปไหน
ไม่ได้เพราะว่าไม่มีเงินน่ะมันจะแย่กว่า
นะ
ก็คือถ้าจะขับรถพาเพื่อนเที่ยวคือถ้า
สมมุติว่าครูเรียนเศร้าครูหญิงเนี่ยจะขับ
รถพาครูเรียมไปเที่ยวไปอะไรนะขับรถริม
ทะเลอันนี้เป็นถนนรถแล้วก็เป็นทะเลก็คือ
ไม่ได้นะ 1 ครูหญิงไม่มีรถ 2 ขับรถไม่
เป็น
[เพลง]
ใช่
แบบนี้แหละแล้วก็บางครั้งอาจจะไม่ต้องไป
ที่ไหนไกลก็ได้
เพื่อนเรียนเคยแบบเสียใจร้องไห้แล้วก็
เรียนก็บอกว่าเดี๋ยวจะไปหาที่บ้านนะ
ค่ะจะไปหาที่บ้านหรือว่าบางครั้งถ้าเกิด
เขาบอกว่านอนไม่หลับนอนไม่หลับจริงๆเนมก็
บอกโอเคเดี๋ยววันนี้เรียมจะไปนอนด้วยที่
บ้าน
ใช่ค่ะก็จะเป็นแบบนั้นเขาก็จะรู้สึกสบาย
ใจมากขึ้น
เหมือนแบบมีคนอยู่ด้วยเนาะใช่
โอเคแล้วแล้วเขาอยากเล่าให้ฟังคือผู้หญิง
คิดว่าถ้าเพื่อนของเรากำลังเสียใจหรือ
เศร้าแล้วแบบถ้าจะคุยกันน่ะก็ไม่ค่อยอยาก
คุยโทรศัพท์ไหมคะไม่รู้นะก็อาจจะอยากเจอ
กันถ้าเลือกได้นะ
คุยกันแบบเห็นหน้าถ้าสมมุติอย่างครูเรียน
เพื่อนเศร้าใช่ไหมคะเพื่อนครูเรียมเสียใจ
แล้วครูเรียนไปหาเขาที่บ้านคุณหญิงคิดว่า
เพื่อนก็รู้สึกดีใช่มากๆก็คือคือครูเรียม
อาจจะถ้าครูเรียมโทรหาถ้ารู้ว่าเขาเศร้า
แล้วเราโทรหาเขาว่าฮัลโหลเป็นยังไงบ้าง
เขาก็รู้สึกดีแล้วแหละค่ะเนาะมีเพื่อนโทร
หาแต่ถ้าเราไปหาที่บ้านไปนอนด้วยกันเนี่ย
เพื่อนก็อาจจะแบบเออรู้สึกอาจจะเศร้าหาย
เศร้าได้เร็วขึ้นมีความสุขได้เร็วขึ้นใช่
ค่ะเพราะถ้าเขาอยู่คนเดียวเขาก็จะคิด
คิดแล้วก็คิดอยู่ในความคิดเยอะๆ
ถ้าเกิดอยู่กับใครสักคนนึงอยู่ด้วยกัน 2
คนเราก็จะคุยกัน
แล้วเขาก็จะออกออกมาจากความคิดที่ไม่ดี
ใช่หรือว่าจริงๆถ้าไปไปหาเพื่อนที่บ้าน
แล้วเพื่อนเป็นคนชอบทำอาหาร
ก็คือหาอะไรทำด้วยกันกับเพื่อนก็ได้อย่าง
ครูเรียมมีเพื่อนสมมุติเพื่อนชอบออกกำลัง
กายเหมือนกัน
แล้วเพื่อนคนนั้นเนี่ยเศร้าอาจจะชวนกันไป
ออกกำลังกายไปว่ายน้ำไปวิ่ง
อันนี้ขับรถอันนี้วิ่งนะคะนักเรียนไม่
เหมือนกันนะ
หาอะไรทำกับเพื่อนในสิ่งที่เพื่อนชอบ
อย่างนี้มันก็เหมือนที่คุณเรียนบอกก็คือ
เขาก็จะลืมในเรื่องที่เสียใจเพราะเขาได้
ลืมได้ทำอะไรใหม่ๆมันก็อาจจะทำให้เขาได้
กลับมาคิดว่าเออเนอะเลิกกับแฟนคนนี้
จริงๆเขาไม่ดีเหมือนที่บอก
ว่าความเศร้ามันก็จะน้อยลงนะใช่เขาอาจจะ
พบว่า
ชีวิตที่ไม่มีสิ่งนั้นที่ทำให้เขาเศร้า
อ่ะมันดีกว่า
ใช่ก็คิดจะเศร้าทำไมเริ่มคิดได้ว่า
จะเศร้าทำไมหรือบางครั้งใช่ไหมเรียมเคย
ได้ยินคำพูดว่า
มีผู้หญิงคนนึงที่อกหักแล้วเพื่อนเขาก็
เลยบอกว่า
แต่งตัวสวยๆเดี๋ยวนี้แต่งตัวสวยๆเดี๋ยว
นี้มีผู้ชายรอเธออยู่อีกข้างนอกเป็นแสน
เป็นล้านคน
ใช่มีผู้ชายดีๆรอเธออยู่ข้างนอกอีกเป็น
แสนเป็นล้านคนแต่งตัวเดี๋ยวนี้ฉันจะพาเธอ
ออกไปข้างนอก
เพราะว่าจริงๆอ่ะถ้าปล่อยให้เขาอยู่แต่
ที่บ้านอยู่ในห้องอยู่กับตัวเองก็เหมือน
ครูเรียมบอกเขาก็จะคิดซ้ำๆเหมือนเดิม
เหมือนเดิมเหมือนเดิมมันต้องพาออกไปข้าง
นอกนะหรือว่าแบบต้องมีคนไปทำอะไรที่ทำให้
เขาไม่คิดอะเนอะเออก็อาจจะเพื่อนก็อาจจะ
ไม่ได้แบบจากเศร้าแล้วก็แบบดีขึ้นเลยขนาด
นี้แต่มันจะทำให้เขาเนี่ยดีขึ้นใช่ไหมคะ
หายเศร้าแล้วก็มีความสุขมากขึ้น
คิดว่ามันก็เป็นหน้าที่เพื่อนใหม่
ก็ถ้าเป็นเพื่อนเพื่อนสนิทเป็นเพื่อนกัน
น่ะบางทีถ้าเพื่อนอกหักก็ไม่อยากโทรศัพท์
หาคุณพ่อคุณแม่ใช่ไหมเพราะฉะนั้นถ้าคุณ
หญิงอกหักผู้หญิงก็ไม่อยากโทรศัพท์หาแม่
ผมบางครั้งแม่ก็โอเคแหละแต่เราอยากคุยกับ
เพื่อนมากกว่าไงมันก็แล้วแต่เรื่องเนาะ
เออก็ไม่รู้เหมือนกันนะคะที่นักเรียนมี
เพื่อนแล้วเพื่อนนักเรียนเนี่ยกำลังเศร้า
[เพลง]
นักเรียนเนี่ยจะทำยังไงให้เพื่อนเนี่ยหาย
เศร้าให้เพื่อนเนี่ยมีความสุขก็คอมเมนต์
คุยกันได้นะคะใช่ค่ะแต่ว่าวันนี้เวลาหมด
แล้วค่ะ
เดี๋ยวเราเจอกันใหม่วีดีโอหน้านะคะนัก
เรียนใช่ค่ะลาไปก่อนแล้วค่ะสวัสดีค่ะ
สวัสดีค่ะ